[Music]
cool as I said my name is Ben Wellington
so I do work at 2 Sigma I've been there
about 10 years and have been doing
basically analysis of data for most of
that time I'm not here to talk about
actually as this kind of reference to my
work specifically at 2 Sigma but rather
I'm gonna talk about some stuff I've
done outside of my work at U Sigma but
using some of the skills I've learned
while they're in a 2 Sigma we were you
know looking to build predictive models
to predict things that are happening in
the future based on what's happen in the
past you know you can when you build
predictive models you can you can take a
lot of you can do it a lot of ways and
and some of the ways that we do it there
is is to really understand our data and
so before you get into that sort of
inferential predictive analytics world
right there's this whole descriptive
statistics world right if you were going
to throw a bunch of stuff into a model
and expect it to do something you should
really understand that and have
hypotheses and have ideas and that's not
always possible with all data sets right
if you're looking at a genome sequence
it might be a lesson to ish in there but
if you're looking at you know traffic
patterns you might have some intuition
so this is a talk about about taking you
know the the deep dive we do on on data
to Sigma and me just kind of taking that
outside the office and playing with
public data and seeing kind of what
comes out and so it's just about asking
critical questions about data and I'm
gonna also talk about some of the best
practices that I've learned while doing
that so and sometimes I feel like I've
become as data storyteller not by not
that wasn't the plan
but as I've as I've gone and and started
to write about things I started to
notice this sort of convergence of of
data journalism and and and good data
science I think that so much of data
science is communication the ability to
communicate things and we don't mean
most science curriculum at least in the
United States doesn't include
necessarily a lot of emphasis on
communication but I imagine if you know
you had all these people studying global
warming and no one could explain it all
right that wouldn't be good and so so I
think there's been a lot of work in
analyzing things but a lot of people are
writing for people like them there's a
lot of blogs where like I took this
Python code and did this and it was
awesome
they're like yeah that's cool but my mom
doesn't think it's cool and like how do
i originally on my mom thinks is cool
because then maybe people outside of
like a very local community would
actually start to listen and so i took
kind of this this this data science um
hat and as was referenced married and my
wife an urban planner and so there she
was and she was she was a that's not
actually her that's not her picture um
but she was going to school at the Pratt
Institute just down the road here in
urban planning getting her master's
degree and she took this statistics
class and she'd go and she'd come home
and they'd be doing these made-up
problems and and she said well I don't
have to learn this I mean no it's good
it's important she's like no it's just
not what I signed up for
um and occurred to me that we're
teaching students t't istic s-- urban
planners in new york city were teaching
on statistics using made-up data with
made-up problems and made-up solutions
in a city full of real data with real
problems that need real solutions and it
was so ridiculous to me that i actually
went down and i somehow it got a meeting
and i said hi you don't know me but I
read you should here's why I think
here's how we should teach statistics
urban planners and they're like oh you
want to teach it and I was like ok and
so now I teach statistics at promise
which has been awesome um three years in
and it's been going really well and
really excited and that's kind of how
how in order to do this class right why
was it possible because there's all this
public data in 2012 here in New York
Mayor Bloomberg at the time their sign
the open data legislation which kind of
says that if you don't have a good
reason to not release data you should
release it so the deef imagine of you
all over any company you work anywhere
you've been imagining you can get any
data anytime unless there's a really
good reason not to how much better would
it be to just get things done
if you didn't have to jump through hoops
to open data but rather someone had to
jump your hopes to not open the data
imagine how productive we could all be
especially in you know someone looking
at data but that's not the way the world
works not the way government works in
theory that's the way this legislation
works says you know obviously if you
have privacy concerns or security
concerns or there's interagency
communication and this list of things
but otherwise we expect it to be public
and you know we're not anywhere near
there but we're starting to start to see
that and that's pretty pretty awesome
and creates all sorts of amazing
opportunity at the time Mayor Bloomberg
said across
government agencies use data to develop
policy implement programs and track
performance each month our
administration shares more and more of
this data with the public at large
catalyzing the the creativity in like an
enterprising spirit of computer
programmers to build tools and help us
all improve our lives that's a 2012 you
of open data and what does the city do
it doesn't get big app competitions
right cuz open 8 is about apps it's all
it is apps let's make lots of apps and
we'll all get on the subway faster it'll
be awesome
so there's all these competitions and
the city's invested in apps ABS ABS ABS
ABS and and something always struck me
about this quote from from from a few
years ago it was like if open data is
about computer programmers then computer
programmers doing a really bad job
making tools for everybody right that's
kind of a sign that we've that computer
programmers haven't reached a point like
this opinator should not be about
computer programmers it should be about
everybody people should be able to go
and say how many how often does this
happen is this true is this not true
we're not there yet but I you know give
it give it some years and we'll be there
so I think this is kind of a smaller
view and I see it more like hey let's
get data they said hey let's get some
pure gamers build some apps and then
we'll give it to the public through
these apps I think it's like no no
forget the apps we're getting tools
let's get this data in the hands of
journalists of people of anyone of you
know hey urban planners of nonprofits
who are trying to prove points really of
all of us and and if we start to do that
we can start to do things and this group
is a particularly you know empowered in
this and and I feel like almost has a
responsibility right there's all this
data that needs to be understood to make
society run better and there are not
that many people yet that can do much
with it why because like I said the
tools aren't there so you know to call
it all of us we need to be making tools
to get these data in the hands of
everybody to sort of help and understand
what's going on in this world
so today the open data portal in New
York you know has these big buttons and
you know I guess they're not buttons but
you click on them and you can get
different types of data there's over a
thousand data sets like 13 or 1400
nowadays and most of which kind of seem
not too interesting but this is not just
in New York phenomenon this is this is
across the United States this is the
open data census run by the Open
Knowledge Foundation you can google it
you can see this list would if the
screen were really long it would go in
the basement there
you know dozens and dozens and dozens of
municipalities that have started to put
data online
that's that access along this act is the
types of data and then the color tells
you you know is it free is it
downloadable I hope so is it all these
different questions and then every city
gets a score and then they're all ranked
and so you kind of had this competitive
open data fight going on so what happens
when we get data to people you can you
can do silly things like this this is
this is my one of the first things I did
a couple years ago when I started this
in 2014 was I just took cyclist injuries
I mean I bike to work every day and I
was like well let's map cyclist injuries
and and sure enough you know we're right
over here but if you were to go over to
Williamsburg you probably see a lot of
cyclists if you have a lot of cyclists
you have a lot of cyclist injuries but
it's also some particularly dangerous
spots there around the bridges which
they're kind of known
there's also Roosevelt Avenue in Queens
which kind of pops out this this was not
sophisticated work but it's just what
you can do if you have access to raw
data this data was always reported by
the number of accidents in this precinct
was this many that's typically the way
data gets reported out but it doesn't
tell you that much right when of these
accidents happening where are they
happening there's one problem with this
particular one which was that it came
from one of these guys right if you if
you like data then you might not like
PDFs and PDFs is where it where data
goes to die right you're a government
agency and you're your you have to put
data out by law right yeah it's true
it's true yeah so you're a government
agency you have to put data out by law
right but you don't really want people
to use it and it's in a database so what
do you do yeah you're the NYPD and you
make this thing which was a 350 page PDF
which is a giant table every row is an
accident and it's hundreds of pages and
this is the way our government is
meeting the hey it's public have fun
you know reporters go at it what is this
actually do in practice well it forces
our volunteer like Civic tech community
to write PDF parsers so we have
government agencies that are Inc that
are basically putting things into PDFs
to make them less accessible then people
wasting their volunteer time to undo it
and that breaks that breaks my heart I
hate it I hate going to civic tech
meetups and seeing 30 percent of the
people they're writing PDF scrapers it's
it's it's it's a travesty and it's where
we are today it's getting better but
it's it's an absolute it's a mess so
this guy John Krauss at the time made
this thing this is for the NYPD's
website and he made this thing called
the NYPD
crash data band-aid and it would go to
their site and every time they put a PDF
he'd make a mere CSV on his site and and
this is where I got the data um
I call this semi open data it's it we're
wasting kind of it's there but we're
wasting that valuable talent of
passionate people to use it and that's
that's not what government's role should
be by the way I should note that there's
a currently an argument between New York
City and Verizon over the the FiOS I
don't know about you but it was supposed
to be citywide to still not in my part
of Brooklyn and so I just caught this
quote in an audit report from New York
complaining about Verizon said because
the files were in PDF format we couldn't
sort or analyze the data was what New
York said complaining about Verizon so
it's not that New York isn't
understanding this fact they are writing
it into final audit reports against
Verizon
and so you know without open data we get
figures well every time you see a table
or chart remember it's somebody's
narrative I never really thought about
this for I started doing this I know
it's obvious but like every number is
somebody want you know one they're ok
telling you and two it's there it's
their analysis but behind this chart is
actually a lot of data it's like all
these cabs and vehicles and licenses and
so I mean you know it's a number here
but there's all this raw information
without it we get things like this with
thing you can start to ask all sorts of
fun questions
I was wondering wondering when rush-hour
is in New York City and so instead of
looking at a taxi as something you can
count I looked at it as a you know you
got longitude pick up drop-off you know
how long it took distance equals you
know the distance actually and you know
how long it took so distance equals rate
times time you get the average speed so
I just took the average speed of the New
York City taxi fleet to see when rush
hour was and I found they were fastest
at 518 in the morning where they're
going Annan standing 24 miles an hour
and then and then it kind of bottoms out
11 1/2 and it stays that way all day so
there's no rush hour in New York just
rush day is about what we learn so our
cabs are going 11 and 1/2 miles per hour
throughout the day this data at the time
came from this form this is called the
Freedom of Information Law request this
is very proactive the fact that an
agency even invited you to request the
data was actually a really big deal most
wouldn't do that you would fill out this
form and they'd say no problem just come
on down to our office with this hard
drive make sure it's unopened drop it
off and pick it up in two days and we'll
give you the data set
and you're like this is not how data
should be spread around it's just a
travesty this is two years ago last year
and this is a Kris Wong at the time I
went and did this and then what did he
do he posted it online and they were
like why this is crazy and they were
actually kind of upset that I was now in
the public but it was very weird and
they eventually kind of now it's all
online you can see on their website it's
also on Google bigquery which is a fun
place to to play with data like this
that's where that chart came from you
can just kind of spin up some things and
ask various questions um so this is kind
of semi-open data to write when you
release data only by making people come
and fill out forms number one how do
they know what to ask for
how do they know that it even exists
right it's convenient if you know you
should assume that the data should be
out and this is sort of a backwards
thing but once again we're improving
things are going in the right direction
so that's awesome so in my requisite a
Venn diagram I you know you take data
scientists urban planning and I and
started this class to make the class fun
I had to make homework assignments to
make homework assignments I had to make
cool things to discover so I kept
discovering things for these students
and I was like well maybe more than my
students think about it I'm gonna put it
on this blog so I started I started
doing things you know this map that I
just showed you came from something and
from 2013 injuries right and I learned
this but as soon as I did it something
funny started happening I started
writing about it and it started to be
written about so I this is literally by
the way file save as heat map like like
in QGIS if you're familiar with spatial
now it's free it's awesome I've learned
it over the last two years just for the
blog it's been a lot of fun if you want
to do spatial analysis I totally highly
recommend it but file save as and this
is not you know I apologize if you're
color blind I'm told this is so bad and
I'm I don't know anything my design I'm
to mess but I made it anyway and all of
a sudden it's being written about a
traffic fatality map Peg's Broadway
stretch of Williamsburg as a deathtrap
whoa
heat map shows and then it was in the
Atlantic suddenly and I'm like this is
crazy I'm at the file save as and this
isn't the Atlantic this is so much fun
this is awesome the Brooklyn paper had a
headline killings Berg I was like oh man
so be careful how you describe your did
I look I never said that I never said
that
but what was happening there it was that
there's this need for information to
quantify things and and as I started to
do more of these to see what the what
people would rewrite about I kind of I
mean this is me just
really posting on a tumblr and tweeting
and then just waiting oh and posting on
reddit that helps you know um so then I
just wait and see what happens and I
experiment I realized that there was
something here that was maybe not as
obvious to people and I'm saying this a
little bit tongue-in-cheek but but
there's there's improv comedy all right
what am I talking about here I happen to
have a background in improv I've been
doing it for a very long time and I'm
there are things you learn doing improv
about telling a story that are important
to get people to listen to you I started
to say well what are these things and
how do they relate to data science so so
my art my argument is that is that you
know like I said I'm being a little bit
tongue-in-cheek on and on The Improv
part in the comedy part but really about
compelling storytelling what can we
learn from storytelling that can make
our data science impactful and make it
work so some things that you learn doing
scenes for people and improv
know connecting with people's experience
if you do a scene and you're you know
brushing your teeth in front of the
mirror and talking to somebody like
everyone's like yeah I know that moment
you're connecting with your audience and
people really appreciate that when
you're doing a scene I always think
about what I'm doing data science or Who
am I doing it for what are the things
that the people I'm talking to care
about you know what do they know and in
New York there are things that are just
ubiquitous like Starbucks right
I was curious how first of all who lived
farthest from a Starbucks in New York
City and I found this person in Inwood I
never went and knocked on the door
because I thought I'd freak him out but
the red star at the top you know but I
also got to be at that the average lot
in New York was less than like three and
a half blocks from a Starbucks which is
absolutely amazing is this useful no but
it was me too starting to kind of
understand things and even when it's not
useful people seemed interested for some
reason I don't I don't know why some
things that are more useful that have to
do with observations you know you ever
try to get that cab at at 4:00 p.m. and
the little off-duty lights off and you
know it's May it's it's there's a
basically there's issue where cabs they
do a shift change in the afternoon in
New York City right between you know
three four or five o'clock so this is
something I've always known and I
decided okay let's just plot the dollars
per minute of the entire New York City
cab fleet throughout on average for the
day so that's what this chart is the
dollars per minute but the fleets making
so we go and
comes down and you can see this this
this dip that dips around 4 or 5 p.m.
which is the perceived problem that you
know even Ed Koch was complaining about
this has been a problem for a very long
time which is the main promise is a
shift change and these garages are not
in Manhattan anymore right they're in
the outer boroughs so in order to do a
shift change the cabs regularly are
driven by two drivers and so at 3 to 4
p.m.
you'd go back to your garage and give
your keys and it in the next person
takes your cab runs of 12 hours comes
back and that's how our cabs are shared
today so this this begs an important
question why does everyone do this at
the same time this is this is and it's
about a 4% of the revenue you can see I
mean I just drew that blue line and
estimated but it's about 4% of the
revenue being lost in cabs by doing this
all at the same time all right
so why do they all do it at the same
time it's an awesome game theory problem
there's only one time in the day where
if you split a cab you'd both make the
same amount of money there's one
equilibrium point where the demand in
the previous 12 hours equals the demand
in the next 12 hours and if you do the
math which I did this is the previous
rolling 12 hours and the next rolling 12
hours with a point they cross means the
amount of money I'm going to make in the
next 12 hours is equal the amount of
make they cross right at between 4:00
and 5:00 p.m. so these the fact that
this is happening there is not a mistake
right it's there if I drove from 3 to 3
and the other person drove it one of you
would make more money or two to two or
one even though they'll fleet would all
make more money it wouldn't be fair so
what would happen I guess I'd have to
pay you it gets that it's too
complicated so we have this locally
optimal but globally animal system going
on so what did the what did the city do
rush hour surcharge you ever got in a
cab and there's a rush hour surcharge
that was the city trying to fix that
what does that do that says if you take
a cab at rush hour you pay this fee the
idea is we're gonna get more people on
the road after 4 o'clock add this fee
supply and demand should work right well
all that money went to the late shift
driver so the early shift drivers like
what the heck we should make our
equilibrium point later into Russia so
it actually backfires and if you do the
you do the math you get this new blue
line instead of the yellow line which
means that the equilibrium point is in a
worse spot than it was and that's where
we are today we all pay a rush hour
surcharge to solve a problem that wasn't
solved but we
all continue to pay it and that's you
know that's the way that's the way the
world works what can you do about it
well New York has has has regulated the
amount you can well the best thing you
do is you you you rent out the cab the
different rates so if you're at office
and you say you drive the two to shift 2
a.m. to 2 p.m. you pay less and you know
$200 and the person who drives 2 p.m. to
2 a.m. gets spends $400
they make 600 either way you know why
can't we do that because New York has
regulated the amount you can charge to
rent out a cab so all of the all the cab
agencies are stuck
they can't split make one more expensive
one less because of regulation and so
until they fix that regulation I don't
see this problem going away but it's an
awesome fun data science problem that
can be had just really by taking
averages and summing right if you think
about all this is is averaging or
something what I want to keep going back
to by the way in this whole talk is that
is that everything I do here is is is
descriptive really mostly just summing
counting and adding and and hope that
I'll come into that you can do a lot you
know if even if you're not an expert at
machine learning there's a lot you can
do just by counting ok another thing
when you're doing a scene you don't want
it to be too complicated you come out
you're like oh it's the King of England
and this happens and this happens and no
one has any idea what's going on I would
argue that same about data science
you've got a data set you got all these
columns and I know people I've seen
people they say oh man it's a lot of
columns and I'm always like well let's
just let's take one or two there are
stories in a column outliers and columns
are stories right the most anything is
interesting to me the least anything is
probably have a story behind especially
when you're just looking at it city like
the most anything right the person who
complains the most like what is that
about the person who called 911 the most
often I mean who knows is it a prank
caller I don't know everything
everything has a story behind it and you
can take any data send any column and
sort and count and you have an
interesting story to tell that's how I
feel
so citibike data is an example where
people have made visualizations and then
all sorts of fun things but I've always
like well let's just take one sort of
idea and explore and for example gender
what can city but tell us about gender
so I made this map using for annoy
polygons by the way and because each dot
in the middle of that is a station if
you're super nerdy appreciate that I
appreciate it
the area up top is is blue this is
basically the gender of our annual
riders in city bike so what you can see
is that it's eighty to ninety percent
ridership up in midtown Manhattan and as
you head down this is before the
expansion that's why this is all kind of
crazy but if you head down into either
the village or Brooklyn you get a a
higher percent of female when I say
higher percent of female I mean you know
up to up to forty five percent female so
not exactly overwhelming but you can
really see differences in the genders
use of our bike share program so this is
once again a dataset with lots of
information but sometimes instead of
trying to visualize at all you just take
one point at a time and you dive in
another another data set that recently
came out was um crime data in New York
this has been something that is that
I've been kind of pushing for for a long
time we got we got a partial win here
which is a incident level crime but only
for the major seven felonies so there
are seven major felonies robbery
burglary murder there's seven of them
and we now can know the approximate
location to the nearest block of each
one of these crimes that time it
happened and instead of what used to be
just a number for a precinct precinct is
a very large space so we used to get
monthly counts per precinct now we get
individual crime and you can do things
for the first time you can study the
city so I was just wondering you know
when do robberies happen the most and
what I found which is kind of astounding
was what the answer was three o'clock
between 3 & 4 o'clock is when the most
robberies happen in New York City and
and and this is where you start to say
well why might that happen and this is
where you can get dangerous right you
try to rationalize what you see in data
science and you come up with all these
explanations then you have to kind of
come up with more experiments to see
whether your explanations make sense or
not right so here the only thing I could
think of was at 3 o'clock
you know school gets out you have all
these kids running around you know and
maybe that leads to a spike so how can
you test that that's sort of the
follow-up question is what we do at you
know this is always important when
you're doing data science it's like if
this then what if it's a journey so how
can you test that well let's split to
vacation days and on vacation days right
the blue or school days the red is
vacation week to wait weekdays whether
on vacation and the
Green or weekend's which you can see has
a lot more of a late-night presence so
you know I have I have I explained the
absolute what is happening here no but I
have a pretty I have a reasonable guess
and this is the kind of thing that we
can start to learn about our city with
with real access to data so keep it
simple not only not only should you know
you not be overwhelmed by how much data
you have every time you look at
something but even the things that
you're doing sometimes can be done very
simply that's what I was saying before
III tend to find a lot of interesting
narratives and counting things and so
when people hear oh you're doing this
data science they're like no it's not
it's kind of like that it's not so bad
it's not so bad once again there are I'm
not saying that this gets you everywhere
my point is only that you can do a lot
here there's a lot more complicated
stuff you can do as well but there's
enough to keep you busy uh here so
another example where do people visiting
New York or coming in from outside go in
New York and how do I get a dataset on
that now this is not a great data
setting this is all sorts of bias issues
and I'll say that up front so you don't
all go oh you didn't think of this but
this is a view of where non New York the
percent of parking tickets given in
every neighborhood that are not given to
New York plates so it's kind of a proxy
for people coming from out of state a
little bit not perfect by any means but
what it is a show well in Midtown the
percent of parking tickets given a non
New York plates as higher as you head
out into say the ends of Staten Island
it becomes much more in New York as far
as a percentage but you can do one of
these for each state so where do people
from New Jersey get the most parking
tickets New Jersey they go into Midtown
and they stop they don't come they don't
come to Brooklyn I don't think if you're
coming in from Connecticut you tend to
get some parking tickets in in coming in
from the north which makes sense my
favorite is people from California
because they only get parking tickets in
the hippest parts of Brooklyn
so we've like we can mathematically show
how cool California is using parking
ticket data which is awesome that's at
Williamsburg and Greenpoint stuff so in
it's in the data right oh and what is
this I'll never forget it wrote about
this and like the New York Post or
somebody called how did you do that like
what is it I'm like I counted like but
I'm like I counted it's counting right
it's about thinking about what the
question to ask is all anyone can anyone
can
do any of this stuff that I'm doing here
just if you take the time and interest
um also many people are experts in
different areas right you're coming from
different different industries and and I
I struggle to do work outside of New
York because I don't have the context I
see a map and I see that all this is
happening here when I see this map in
New York I know exactly what's happening
right when I see that map in in LA I
don't well I guess it doesn't make sense
because the California plates but if I
see this map in Boston I wouldn't have
any idea why this is lit up and that
that's hard it's good to take the time
to educate yourself and the thing that
you're studying don't just treat your
data as a black box that you're just
gonna throw everything and think that
you'll just you know whatever take the
time to understand the thing you're
looking at it goes a long way
whether that's reading up on it right I
know you'll see patterns and it's to
educate yourself about the ins and outs
of what you're studying can you make it
so much farther so in an improv scene
right like if someone's gonna play a
lawyer and it's a courtroom scene and
somebody actually is a lawyer in real
life it's like such a better seen than
when somebody's pretending to be a
lawyer because they actually know what
they're doing and it gets across how
much more crisper and that's kind of my
analogy there to the improv world so
what so what III do a lot of things just
based on observation right and as I walk
around New York I think about both
things that could be data sets but also
things that I'd like to measure um if
you have I think on 14th Street there is
a I believe it's a like I think it's
like a Taco Bell KFC near Union Square
somewhere and it's never felt like the
the most clean place had ever been and
and and I started to notice that these
combination fast-food restaurants didn't
seem the same as the other fast-food
restaurants right this is kind of thing
that I might have just like all right
move on with my life but with open data
you can answer such questions so what I
did is I took all their like for example
here the Dunkin Donuts here the
baskin-robbins and these are violations
for health inspection scores higher is
worse so anything below a 13 is an a
anything between 13 to 27 is it B so
what do we see Dunkin Donuts gets a
fourteen baskin-robbins 13 combination
gets 16 a little worse but as we get
down here it gets pretty amazing Taco
Bell's got A's a Casey's get low B's but
combinations are through the roof
28 points like more than double more
than double it's amazing and same with
Papa John's in Subway's so there's
something about combination restaurants
and it's not you know
they share a kitchen often so there's
something it may be me some people
suggested it's about some human
psychology well that's not my that's not
my thing it's not my thing and so that
no one cleans it I don't know I don't
know the reason but I found it
interesting while I was there I had to
rank all the fast food in New York right
yeah you kind of have to if you're
looking at the data and what did I find
I found that White Castle was the
cleanest fast food chain in New York now
this was a media excitement so I'll
never forget Fox local Fox station sent
a camera crew down to the White Castle
parking lot seen on TV that night and
they're interviewing this lady and
they're like Bella wood she's like I
knew it was healthy this once again your
data can be misinterpreted be careful
out there I I ha put out a statement
saying something like well he used 12
years of data how'd he only used five
years of data it would have looked
better I was like okay you can always
select your data if you want and
actually White Castle put out a
statement that was probably the least
progressive statement I'd heard but it
was well we always tell our employees if
you have time to lean you have time to
clean Wow all right
okay well that's clean but at the what
expense all right another thing I think
about data science is who you writing
for right what is it what is like
sometimes you want to measure something
you don't know how to measure it and it
can be frustrating so the question is
you know what is it you're exactly
trying to say and can you create an
index or a metric or this is something
that's always on my mind all the time
when doing this kind of work and and I
had this data set which was really I I
mean luckily it's not lunch time this is
called the fecal coliform measurement so
what is this it's a bacteria that's
present with fecal matter in waterways
and so what the city does is they
measure in different points around the
city you can get longitude latitude you
can see what amount of the bacteria
that's present in with sewage basically
is there and so for everything you can
see on any day that they measured which
may be weekly you can see what the level
is now this is interesting why is why
first of all why do we have a lot of
sewage in our water well there's various
reasons the main reason is we have this
things called combined sewer outflows
CSOs combined sewer outflows are
basically the fact that if you flush
your toilet
and you pour water down like the street
great drainage they actually go into the
same system in New York because it's
just an old system and so that's great
and efficient until it rains really hard
and then it's not so good because the
capacity is reached and so what do they
do they have to empty into our waterways
this happens many times a year this is
not like a once in a lifetime event
you'll see that beaches will close for a
few days sometimes after large rain
events around New York City that's the
reason it's happening so anyway you got
this dataset where where most of the
time things are okay and then there's a
skewed you know then there's this huge
outliers then it's kind of ok and then
it's so not ok and then it's ok again
and so I was like how do i how do I do
this in a map right and m''d the mean at
any spot I would get some number which
is the milliliters per something of
coliform no one cares right I did the
mill no one cares about the measurement
no one has any idea what this bacteria
is and besides a mean we're just I don't
care if it's a thousand times over
disgusting or a hundred times over
discussing is just disgusting I the
means gonna or the medians not gonna
help either because I'm most days it's
kind of just fine right so what is it
you're trying to say so I said I'm gonna
measure the percent of days where would
be illegal to get in the water by state
law right so it's taking a data set and
then the thing you're measuring is a
little bit more relatable to people and
that's T if you want people to take
something away from your data giving
them something in am unit that they
don't have a conceptual understanding of
it's not helpful but you know in your
canal you've got 14 milliliters for
something of this Calliphora
though one cares like did you know in
your canal if you get twenty percent of
the time it's actually it's so gross
would be illegal to get in the water
there's two days same data different
explanation different impact that's a
big deal so what did I find I found this
place Coney Island Creek not Coney
Island or you swim but on the backside
ninety-four percent of samples taken
over five years had levels above above
legal limits now up until two weeks ago
I wondered why that was and then two
weeks ago is looking at the news and I
saw this article apartment dumps two
hundred thousand gallons of sewage per
day in the Coney Island Creek this is
from two weeks ago and it turns out that
for the last ten years these like twenty
buildings have just been dumping all of
their sewage there what's amazing is
that is that no one picked that up with
it I mean we're measuring the city is
measuring can we do something with it
like this is my point
outset is the worst in the city and yet
it took another two years I wrote that
two years ago for somebody to then
discover this and not relate it to the
work but because somebody you know we're
added somebody out or something so I'm
interested to see how much that drops
and and you know I'll check back in six
months and see if that was actually the
culprit I imagine it is because that's
pretty high um
so another thing think outside the box
and scenes when people are doing uh you
know they want to see something creative
something different and sometimes the
thing you want to measure isn't there's
no data set on that you're like if only
I knew X but there's no data set for X
how do I figure that out and sometimes
you know so I was wondering when people
decorate for Christmas there's no data
center when people decorate for
Christmas but there is is an emergency
room visit data set which tells you
items that have injured people at
emergency rooms and so if you
cross-section that with Christmas
ornaments and ladders you get this chart
this is the number of people visiting
emergency rooms who are injured by
Christmas ornaments per day here is what
Thanksgiving week depending on the year
this is over five years of data over
seven years data so depends on the year
but it's sure enough people start
decorating around Thanksgiving people
seem to be injured but not so badly on
Christmas and that you can tell people
tend to maybe start taking their stuff
down after Christmas but then spike
right after New Year's so and I've also
I'm pretty sure it's safer to take down
Christmas decorations and put them up
from this chart I'm not entirely sure um
sometimes you take a dataset you want to
use it sort of in a whole new way like
this another one example is was um I was
wondering where the best place in New
York is to go listen to go watch illegal
fireworks right so what better place in
the user 3:01 complaints about illegal
fireworks so if you go to the whatever
area has the most complaints is probably
the best firework show right so this is
a map of a tonight and I landed in
Inwood I'll never forget the next day
the New York Times this is like 2014
wrote an article that was basically all
about the Inwood fireworks not because
they read my article but they did real
reporting well I was like on my couch
but they ended in the same place saying
wow in wood is the best place for these
fireworks and I kind of posted this map
the day before and it was like okay well
least we landed the same the same
location just kind of neat by the way
firework complaints to three-on-one are
hilarious
because they they start in June and then
like right after 4th of July that is
just kind of disappear so you have all
these people who have them and they have
to use them and then they use them all
and then I just signup limits after like
the fifth of July and then you don't see
it pick back up until that June 3rd 4th
when people start to think ahead ok so
that's a bunch of examples and I'm gonna
end by telling you about how I've tried
to make an impact with all this right
some of this is goofy like finding where
to watch fireworks right hopefully you
can think about some of those best
practices that apply them in ways that
might be more impactful to you than some
of the stuff but I'll tell you how I've
been trying to make an impact here in
New York by by doing some math um one
thing I did which which is less data and
more just kind of math was kind of fun
was this is from this is the machine as
it looked about a year and a half ago
two years ago and I noticed that I'd be
riding the subway and I I bike a lot so
I don't have an annual card and I'd ride
and swipe and I'd end up with two
dollars and forty-five cents on my card
and at the time the fare was 250 and
what it turned out is that that is
because it had this bonus right and if
you hit these are the three buttons in
New York offered you when you would go
to a machine and buy by credit card that
middle button there gives you $19.95 and
the fare is 250 so I explained why I
would get $2 and 40% now you can refill
but it's very irritating to like not
know how much you have and this money to
sit in your card and I guess the MTA
gets tens of millions of dollars a year
on expired cards and your visitors to
come to the city right and and I'm at
you know it's one of the only places
where you go in and you can't say I want
to buy three rides it's like I want to
put this much money on the card which I
hope is mathematically five percent less
than three right no one can do that
so everyone overestimates and it works
out really well for for the MTA I'm not
saying it's on purpose but it works out
well for them and it does so I wrote
about this and this was this is one of
these things that kind of people related
to and I got this great quote from it
from the MTA saying these machines do
not hold an infinite amount of change
and the denominations are suggested to
ensure there is ample change to
accommodate customers that pay with cash
okay but those credit card machines to
that being said we will certainly look
at this as part of the process involved
in rolling out the next scheduled fare
increase Thank You MK so they're gonna
tie me into the fare increase slated for
next year well done so the fare increase
came this is from last year and enough
from earlier this year they raised the
fare and I I know I was gonna happen or
what
remember um and I ran down to the
machine and he was like you had
something but no they added a new button
today if you use the empty a vending
machine you'll see the same old buttons
and this new button there
27:25 if you hit that button you get
exactly eleven rides and no change so
that's my button yeah that's good you
got to use it yeah now by the way
there's no red circle that's my red
circle no one would ever know to use
that button but me but it's the only
button that gives you an even balance so
OCD is united okay so I love that button
it's good so small wins hopefully one
day you'll be able to also then say how
much does it cost to ride the subway
four times and by that I know that's
crazy like I mad you in your store and I
spend this much like you got three and a
third of an apple that sucks
that's what that's what happened in the
subway today so we haven't won this
battle other data that's been that I've
looked at this is health inspection
scores in New York City back to these
ones that I was ranking the fast-food
chains on um once again we're counting
here how many scores get how many
restaurants get each score what happens
is you get these one point or two point
values or three point depending on the
severity and you sum up all your
violations during the inspection and if
it goes above thirteen you get a B so
what we have here are the A's in green
we're the B's in blue and the C's in red
okay so what do we see happening around
like twelve and thirteen there's an
that's not that you'd think this curve
would be kind of smooth right twelve
points 13 points fourteen points right
but it's not at all it's all bunching up
at 13 and 12
it's all bunching up at 13 and 12 so why
what is that about right I mean it's
clearly some sort of like grade
inflation going on right this is not a
person who's like I'm gonna get six
problems and not seven live in advance
okay this is not this is not organically
happening this is this is happening
based on the inspectors you know
discretion um which can be problematic
right because as soon as you add
discretion in to that level people have
biases and they might treat different
groups differently and that can cause
all sorts of problems so I wrote about
this and the Department of Health said
inspectors are not instructed to offer
leniency just to cite what they see that
final score is based on extent of the
violations that the inspector observes
so that was a department health said so
they really didn't say anything at all
this is two years ago and I just went
back last week and rechecked and I said
well at least now they know
about it and how do you fix this by the
way you just make one of these
histograms for each of your employees
and then it'd be very obvious it's
probably all of them actually it's
probably human nature I'm not I'm not
saying I wouldn't end up with the same
kind of history I'm even if I didn't try
but if you did you could see where the
most extreme ports and you could say hey
you got to be careful here or if you I
mean it'd be too expensive imagine if
you had two people for restaurant doing
different parts of it and then you're
responsible for X 1 for Y I mean this
would disappear right because no one
would know my decision doesn't but those
others haven't rolled out so basically
nothing's happened here unfortunately so
how I have made a difference there but I
keep keep browsing um you know another
area that that I've looked why I showed
you some taxi stuff earlier um when you
ride a taxi you got this you got this
question do you want a tip 20% 25% or
30% right and most most people tip
actually 20% and it gets 40% of us tip
20 not most people but that's the most
common amount some people hit other and
tip different amounts but did anyone
ever stop and think about 20% of what
cuz I didn't for the first 7 years I was
in New York riding a cab
till I was like it's 20% of what ok it
turned out and this was this was amazing
to me turned out that it depended on the
programmer of the computer in the back
of the cab that if they were written by
creative mobile technologies programmers
that you would be whipping on top of
tolls and taxes and surcharges if
they're written by VeriFone programmers
then it would be tipping only on top of
the fare in the surcharge meaning that
those that had a computer in the back
branded by create mobile technologies
those drivers made to 300 dollars more a
year because the computer in the back
was programmed with a different
multiplier for tipping and this is in a
very highly regulated industry this is
not like you know it's reading about
taxis is ridiculously regulated so I
wrote about this and got my favorite
government response ever we appreciate
that work that way into his analysis and
we're giving it a thorough read so the
TLC said to the media which was pretty
awesome but about three weeks later they
reprogrammed half the fleet of cabs in
New York so now we all tip on top of
tolls and taxes
so be careful if you go through a tunnel
just know that you're tipping on top of
you know
my apologies y'all but at least it's
equitable and at least you don't have to
you know you start to think you know you
know you're paying extra you don't
wonder if you're paying extra ha got him
that'll show him drivers all making 300
hours but it's good I I don't I just it
just felt it felt broken and I'm glad
I'm glad that it effects even if it
wasn't exactly how I planned um
NYPD they have Twitter handles in the
back of all their cars now I don't know
if you noticed not each individual car
but each precinct you'll see a little
bird on the back of the card next time
one drives by you check it out and
they've been using Twitter because they
want to get more involved with community
and I thought this once the fifth
Precinct had a 115 percent increase in
bicycle collisions this year police
officers will be enforcing violations
like bicycles hash tag bike space safety
all right so there's a bunch of things
here so I saw this tweet a hundred and
fifteen percent increase in bicycle
collisions things in like real world
things like that don't move like that
unless you so there's like a volcano
opened and like everyone was falling in
that doesn't happen so I was like oh
maybe they meant fifteen percent I don't
know but I do know that they're sending
out all these officers so I better
figure out what's going on here with the
open data you can actually do this so I
went and I analyzed and I found there
had been a like a ten percent decrease
in bicycle collisions so I wrote about
this I was like you know and and what
are the NYPD say then say anything then
we didn't have to so they didn't respond
but imagine a world where as government
does this they show their work like it's
not that's not that crazy it's like hey
this is my stat by the way it's from
this source and here's a here's a
jupiter notebook that has the the work
you know you guys laugh you guys laugh
but like new orleans started to do it
boston just started last week they're
posting chicago you can download the
health inspection prediction algorithm
now online so we're starting to see this
happening i'm not saying it's gonna
happen in the NYPD anytime soon but it's
starting we're getting there it's not
that crazy imagine saying a fact that
backing it up with data is not like
sci-fi right i mean it kind of is but
it's not alright last last two for you
this is a these are these are fire
hydrants in new york but not just any
fire hydrants these are the fire
hydrants that generate the most parking
ticket revenue
right so they all have a revenue right
you're a hydrant you're sitting there
car gets too close
yeah 102 15 bucks you sit that you add
that up per year you make good money
being a hydrant so I mapped that the
hundred most prolific hydrants and what
do we see on the Upper East Side they
love hydrants I know it's but I also
found these two hydrants on the Lower
East Side they were making together over
fifty five thousand dollars a year just
being hydrants right more than minimum
wage just being a hydrant so what was
that about what was amazing here is this
this this is what I said the most
anything has a story right this is just
a group by sort literally it's a group
by sort and yet there's an entire story
behind it do this in any data set you
ever get as human interaction and you'll
have a story there's so many stories in
the world if only we had more time to
tell these stories uh so 55,000 what was
this about well there was this hydrant
and it had this look like a bike lane
and then a car in these cars a park here
and they all I'm not near the hydrant
there's a bike lane here I'm fine
but the police officers disagreed the
d-o-t thought it was a great parking
spot they cop they painted a parking
spot but the NYPD didn't think it was a
good parking spot so this went on for a
very long time and if you go on Google
Street View you can see years and years
of tickets on people's windshields like
you can go through the years this is a
Google Street View shot and you can just
see the orange on people so the d-o-t
said while the DoD has not received any
complaints about this location will
review the roadway markings and make any
appropriate alterations and I waited a
few weeks and they repainted the spot so
so this was like you know generating uh
these two spots fifty five thousand
dollars a year which maybe don't sound
like a lot but it is for all the people
who have to go through the hassle of
going through so where do we use we're
using data at a very local level to fix
things um and we're able to do it on
this because it's public but so much it
is not public yet and so we can't you
know really get down deep into fire and
things like that which are really
critical to our to our lives and the
last example for you is another parking
ticket one it turns out that I I had
that you can actually park in front of
pedestrian ramps in New York City for
the last like seven years um why is that
well a legislator who was very a very
car driving neighborhood who represented
you know parking wanted to make more
parking spots and the claim is if you
make a curb cut and you don't have a
stop sign or a crosswalk that it's not a
very safe place to enter the street and
it makes sense right if you walk into a
street and there's no stop signs that's
kind of dangerous so we said well the
solution is to
let cars park there that part I don't
understand the inference there but that
is what was decided so it is legal to
park in these spots and there's one in
my neighborhood that goes into a that
doesn't like lead anywhere interesting
and I've parked at it from time to time
and I've gotten tickets and you know I
fight them and like sometimes I fight
them and the judge would be like now
it's illegal I mean I know it's illegal
and I'm like this is so frustrating you
realize that with data it's not about
your personal fight I can actually prove
this on a citywide as a citywide problem
instead of fixing my piping problem I
want to fix everyone's parking problem
so I started researching where
pedestrian ramp tickets given the most
outliers right so look at the number one
spot and this it was a legal spot number
two spot was a legal spot number three
that's there's no there's no crosswalk
legal spot
number four yellow paint by the way in
New York has no meaning somebody painted
a yellow but it's a legal spot anyway I
went to number five with the number ten
with the number 100 I went the number
200 I skipped a five-hundred legal spot
it's like whoa I think this is start do
the math two and a half million dollars
a year being collected at legal parking
spots so I decided to map out them the
biggest ones and and and let the NYPD
know and got this response mr.
Wellington analysis identified errors
the Department made an issuing parking
someone says it appears to be a
misunderstanding by officers on patrol
of a recent abstruse change in the
parking rules way to get that in there
it's not your fault it's the laws fault
we appreciate mister like to bring this
to anomaly to our attention they then
went on to institute electronic
monitoring issue retraining for all the
officers and start issuing refunds for
those who were asked forgetting these
acts in these parking lots of the last
five years so so once again this is just
about using data in in in in counting to
find real meaningful impactful things
and in this case its parking but in all
of your cases are something else right
whether it's it's click logs whether
it's whether it's music listens there's
real stories and all this stuff and you
don't have to always make predictive
models to find real stories sometimes
what you're doing needs it sometimes it
does it sometimes in order to know what
those models get you need to understand
what's downstream you need to understand
the data and understand the data you
need to find things like this and then
you can feed that to your predictive
models but if you don't the time to do
that garbage in garbage out
so I lend data storytelling connect with
people try to convey idea keep it simple
Explorer you know best figure out what
exactly are trying to say think outside
the box and um working with urban
planners III you know just using Excel
they were able to take what used to be a
data set that has by the way tens of
thousands of rows and I said can you
tell me in this neighborhood around our
school what type of cars caused the most
accidents this is somebody who doesn't
can't program right and they you know
the homework they make this chart and
that's to me that's where we're getting
that's awesome like it's a thousand of
rows in a CSV file and they can go and
Excel pivot table which is like a good
intro to I don't know any my data
science but I want to write and it's
it's amazing and even people who don't
even use computers as a high school
program called city term looking at
graffiti complaints and you know colored
pencils right you can get so I'd argue
anyone can be a that a storyteller my
site is is I quant NYC isn't me on this
if you want to keep up with my
shenanigans with with New York and also
as mentioned work with great people like
like Wes he heard earlier at to Sigma
check that out if you want to learn more
about some of that and I'll open it up I
think very few minutes but a few minutes
for questions so we'll go with that
thank you
[Applause]
pay teachers more comment as we need to
pay teachers more than we don't know
that's that's a separate study that's
waiting to happen
no I hear that I hear that yeah yes
it was slow going it was very much a
legislative branch we thought this was
great for a while and sorry I think it's
it's a cultural shift so imagine if
someone could look at everything you do
and then talk about it is that a good
thing or a bad thing when I went in the
NYPD case I gave them 30 days notice and
my theory was that if I give them 30
days notice before writing about it that
it was more collaborative than it's not
a gotcha like these things I know I
presented here is kind of funny but
often they're me trying to say hey
government like we can all do this
together I think the more you open the
better government can run not the more
you open the more dumb I'm going to make
you look right so there's there's a
cultural shift in has to do with the
organization the department who works
there they're experienced and it's still
very much closed people are very
terrified of all this I think they're
terrified of work like this as well but
a lot but like if you went and listened
to the mayor's office of data analytics
testified the last hearing he was his
big example was reading quotes from that
post so the city is saying how
successful their open data has been is
citing this last example themselves so
that should give you a sense that that
there is a cultural shift that they
realize this is you know let's work with
people not not not be afraid of them
my tracking change from year to year I
mean every everything you look at might
have a temporal thing
one of the biggest annoying things in
New York does and most cities do is they
don't they don't do a great job with
historic data so you can go online and
see like all taxi licenses that are
currently active but you can't see all
taxi license ever given all right so
what does that I think it's not even
useful I just I want to see the history
you can see all sidewalk licenses you
can see current building permits like
how am I gonna study how things go over
time if you can't store snapshots of
your data over time so a lot of data
unfortunately is current and it's up to
kind of the community to start logging
this stuff and I've been doing it in
some datasets in general yes anything
over time is interesting for sure
but like you know how is the mayor doing
is a very broad thing which I think I'm
not trying to solve I'm trying to find
micro instances where we can make things
run better and more efficiently
certainly you can see hey you know you
look at numbers about stop and frisk you
know they've reduced over this mayor
with the previous mayor and so if that's
something that you're passionate about
then I guess that's going in the right
direction there's all these metrics but
who know what is success and what is not
is anyone's guess what's the name of the
Meetup you mentioned earlier so there's
there's an a Braille organization called
Code for America and they have a brigade
here in New York called beta NYC beta
NYC is a civic tech group they get
together and work on projects that can
help government run better yeah a lot of
software things as well thank you Ben
thanks everyone see you next year